so okay we're live streaming now
okay welcome everybody it's three
o'clock
um 6th of June infrastructure Services
meeting
and I'm going to start with apologies we
have those from Council Boyle councilor
Dermody Reverend cook
can I have uh welcome pania can I have
someone please move those thank you Mia
thank you Leslie
put that all those in favor
takes us there's no I haven't received
any Declarations of interest and it
takes us to the minutes
uh of the 2nd of May infrastructure
meeting
can I have someone move that they're
true and correct thank you Alex
seconded
second Leslie uh before I put that out
are there any anything anyone wishes to
raise
in those minutes right okay I'll put
that all those in favor hi yeah that's
Carrie thank you
we've got two major Lane items today one
in public and one in public excluded
and they are the waste net minutes from
the fifth as it was it the 15th
yeah the 18th of May for about 15th and
18th 15th and 18th it's kind of someone
please move that received those
I think you
counselor Stewart seconded
counselor Campbell I'll put that all
those in favor all right
against carrot
that now takes us to
Solid Waste update
assistant
is it welcome
if you'd like to pull a microphone up
Plus thank you
and everybody can I take this report as
red sure
right
so it did it shows that we are tracking
with
um waste of landfill slightly better
than last year yes that's right
does anyone have any questions regarding
the report
yes
not really a question just a bit more of
a statement I guess it's it's great to
have these reports that track our uh our
Solid Waste compared to last year or
projections but the bottom line I guess
is that
and the recent National report that came
out said Southern was by far the worst
solid waste management area in the
country so that I guess going forward's
a challenge for us
yeah well um Annie can I ask the
question
um you don't have to answer and if you
don't have the figures
um but back
when all this started in 2010 uh the key
the key Target point was 650 kilograms
per
per household now are we do we are we
above that 650
um we are tracking
435 roughly now
um that's last quarter yeah that's super
per capita we have reported last quarter
so we are below right right so I mean
the whole thing is about waste
minimization yes
yes and waste minimization is is really
stopping at going to landfill
and hopefully not on the footpath yeah
yeah
um we still have some ways going to land
for now like you can see but we are
tracking better I mean like we are
getting out to public we are putting the
message in there and hopefully and we
got a new waste minimization officer now
hoping to see a good change next year
right now excellent any questions yeah
okay there's recommendations are that
we received the report note the data
Trends and note the recycling data
Trends as well
you move that rear
yeah I've seconded thank you partner
I'll put that all those in favor all
right against that cave it takes us now
to road closures for the event on the
16th of June
um
Russell oh no sorry Andrew apologize
I've got my light ringing for this one
everyone else is at high meal or
unavailable
right okay
well this is a great time to talk about
potholes and that's right I'll take
those ones and give you a response to
the next next meeting yeah legal
potholes
um but this is the ongoing issue that
we're we've identified and starting to
work through in terms of the joint
duties and trying to understand to make
sure that when we do have events on land
which is otherwise controlled by us that
we understand what's going on what the
risks are associated with the event
that's occurring uh and
um how we're managing those risks and
who's responsible most importantly for
managing those risks so that's why I'm I
do have some knowledge of this paper
even though it doesn't have my name on
it I've been working with the the
roading team to make sure that we
address those issues and you'll see
that's picked up in the language that's
in there around
making sure that we're clarifying the
roles uh who's got the duty and who is
the best place to manage that Duty so
we've made some inquiries around the
nature of this event as much as the road
closest that are actually to occur
yes I've got a couple questions
um so
what is the actual event that's got an
activation event
what what is that because it doesn't
actually say
anywhere really no and that's happened
the fact that there's going to be a road
closure I guess the first questions
Great South as a CCO of
Council so who does the ultimate risk
lay work if something should go wrong
good technical question
um
obviously in the sense that the Great
South is now a separate legal entity
being a company
um obviously you've got a a legal
boundary between yourself there but it
doesn't that doesn't solve the joints to
pcbu issue
um so in the event that obviously Great
South for whatever reason found itself
in financial difficulty Council may need
to step into that space But but you do
have a legal separation because it's a
separate legal entity but you still have
the joint pcb's new Duty
um in with respect to your first point
and that was something that we tried to
I suppose subtly highlighting the the
paper we first became aware of this
event on the 15th of May
um and I think it's fair to say that
everyone's a little bit caught by
surprise around the speed of this event
coming up and so we've been trying to
sort of uh understand what it is from
from a a pure Council perspective as
well as the broader Council in terms of
what is the activation is it something
that we want being given at the the city
center activator role is something that
Council rates for and funds so as far as
we can ascertain basically there are
some events to occur it's effectively
it's a group called Flame entertainment
that are coming down to do some fire
dances their description
um they'll leave that to people's
uh imagination that's as far as I can go
in terms of helping you what that means
but we've had a look at their risk uh
management plan and how they managed to
risk for the actual financing event uh
that all seems to be up to scratch as
far as where aware and the best place to
manage that so we're we've seen that
we're comfortable with that the issue
that we have on top of that is obviously
the number of people
um they're expecting maybe 1500 people
or so over the night with potentially
around 500 people roughly uh per
um uh per event I suppose is the best
way to describe it there'll be three or
four different uh times when they do the
the dancing over the period that is
closed and so obviously there's some
issues there around more broadly people
management
and we've made some inquiries as to what
they intend to do in that space as well
so if I sorry
so if I'm understanding right
this road request closure
is for an event that
requires
a traffic management plan
a safety plane but then having multiple
events in and around this area it's the
one group in the flame Entertainment
Group but they'll be performing three to
four times over the period that the
roads closed so I think the event the
inverted Commons the road closing starts
around five a little bit after five then
the event starts around six and runs
through till eight or thereabouts and
there'll be uh the the performance will
occur for 10 minutes there'll be a 20
minute break then the performance will
occur again
um so there's a number of performances
over the over that period So you're
satisfied with the health and safety
plan
for the actual
um flame is is fine and the traffic
management when we're always again
fairness to everyone we're always very
good on the traffic management side
um okay
if they get the numbers that I expect
there'll be there's some issues
um they're just just potential issues
I'm not saying and and they've got some
uh crowd control in place
um
well
it's it's not any more detailed than
that at this stage I think that in
yeah I suppose this is where I would so
you feel we don't have enough data to
make a decision today
Great South as you've been organized a
best place to to assess what they need
to have in place for that
um we don't have a lot of detail around
what that is other than that I've
flagged with them if they have 500
people that's a that's a group of people
that potentially needs management
um we've also obviously icl's aware and
so they'll have people in place from
their side
um
they're assessing their risk and making
a call uh
I I wouldn't necessarily say we wouldn't
do it differently but but am I say I'm
not satisfied but I wouldn't know they'd
go that far either
thank you okay thank you uh Mr Mia just
to give some background to this
um
so the city uh contracts out the
activating position to Great cell
I recently had a meeting with xiaomi and
suggested to her that we need some
activity in this area got the body to
close off both the air scan down streets
from time to time got a lot of feedback
from the 18 to 30 year old when we
surveyed uh before last Christmas and
after after the Christmas period where
they wanted more events in the street
with the Street closed and they also
wanted local bands to be able to play
there at night time and the question of
you know whether you could have a
parties only or not which we've had on
Don Street and the past was raised the
issue with the contract was between city
council and great South was the
activation was really only for four or
five events a year and I said well we
actually need more than that certainly
in the summer months we do we we had one
recently that had pipe bands and could
detectives it was great a lot of people
in the inner city and the retailers got
a lot of benefit from that so I guess
this is probably driven by me having a
meeting with champion saying hey look we
need to get on and get some activity
here over the weekends when the weather
permits
so and it might bring me that on a day
that we would have children stuff during
the day and and then as we get towards
the evening we have more adult focused
or teenage focused activities as well
and just on that point we're aware that
there's another three uh events planned
through the rest of this so the the year
where there'll be similar applications
for road closure
okay Leslie thank
you I think um could
could CEO because I heard it being
referred to as a CCO
so it is a CCO I think Gracie Hopkins
who acknowledges it's a CCO
um there'd be some technical argument
about whether it's a ccto but it's
definitely a CCO as in a council
controlled organization given that the
councils jointly uh the shareholders in
Great South
thinking
[Music]
this is a new event
and we're actively trying as the city
council to encourage
new exciting activities in this area of
the city
so although you were a little bit
hesitant in replying for the amount of
detail you have philosophy
you are obviously here to recommend
that we go again in the circumstances I
think
eating
yes is the short answer
and that's what I suppose that's why I
flagged there are some further events
and and again as we mature in this space
so well event organizers
um so that
I'm comfortable given where we're coming
from that where we've done more than we
would have done historically We Now
understand the issues a bit more and
we'll monitor it and see how we go and
see what occurs but I'm I'm comfortable
that it's a
the the way of discussed who's got
responsibility for the different and and
the Great South have that responsibility
and that they're going to undertake it
at this stage and we don't have any
reason to expect that they won't
undertake it properly as I said we might
do something different but that doesn't
mean that what they're doing is wrong
which is the difference and at this
stage we've got no reason to expect that
what they're doing is wrong
so just
just
in any risk that you're going toward
that tension as you responsibility
he he really put me on the spot there
but yes it's a short answer thank you
oh
that's true so I mean 100 support the
idea of more stuff happening there so I
mean
but my question really is about process
Andrew because what we're asked to do as
council is approve the closure of the
road we're not asked to approve the
event but us to approve the closure of
the road so could I could I just ask who
does approve the club the the actual
event because it could be anything
couldn't it so it is fine as a green
um the road closure but I'm assuming
that somewhere Upstream that there is
somebody approving the event you know
that it's not something untoward or you
know you know what I mean so so how what
is the process for that uh well that I
suppose that's this joint PCB obligation
we are approving the event
um
yeah but who physically approves the
event do do we have an officer who at
some point looks at this and says yes I
approve fire dancing and and that that's
where it will come through as the road
closure and so uh road closure is one
that comes up it has come up more
recently but for instance the same thing
uh will occur if an events do occur on
Parkland
um you just won't have the road closure
part there'll be uh the parks operations
team effectively will be assessing the
event
um and giving some advice where
necessary to yourselves if if Council
needs to approve it it's just the road
closure one comes to you more regularly
because you have the power to close it
right I understand that but but who does
actually approve the event and first
place so this particular event
has it been approved by officers before
it comes to us okay so so that's my
question so you know I'm a little bit
concerned I'm going to support it right
but I'm a little bit concerned about
buying a pig in a book right
that if there is nobody approving you
know Alex buying a pig and a pork
yeah I'm sorry I'll explain it to you
later
I'll explain it to you later I'm a
little bit I'm a little bit concerned
that
um that there is nobody who approves
these before they come here I mean we're
approving the road closure so I'm not
saying there's anything I'm toward fire
dancing but I don't know what the next
one will be the other one after that'll
be so it would be I mean it seems to me
that there should be a process in-house
not involving Council involving officers
who look at you know these activation of
things and say yep that's something you
want in a set here a bit concerned a bit
more
but
I I hear what you're saying and and
really I suppose implicit in the
approval from staff is that the papers
come to you so that if staff form the
viewing with a future event that the
risk is not been properly managed or
cannot be properly managed you won't see
the paper
and this one again uh and I'm not trying
to
um
disparage anyone or the process but this
came out fairly short notice I might
interrupt I think I've got the chief
executive uh wanting to jump in here
thank you through yourself to you we've
actually got two issues
um or two items here that you're talking
about for approval
one is the council acting as a regulator
in relation to the road closure side of
it which we are looking at the events
purely from are they are the events
being contained if they have a health
and safety plan in place and that's
what's before you
your secondary question which I think is
the one you're talking about is who
actually approved the event to the
nature of the event to actually occur in
this case it's through Grace Great South
we have a contract with them to activate
four events we need to work through that
process to make sure that those four
events are acceptable from a council
point of view we've not clearly got that
process in place this is the first one
off the ranks we've asked them to get
get the events moving it's the first one
that was presented to us and it's come
through this channel so in essence we're
approving both at the same time that
we're comfortable to get an activation
event and that we close the road
the other X item from there is we will
need to work on a process in relation to
the event approvals for the activation
make sure council is comfortable with
the nature of those events I'll take
that on board
um it's cheap executive to sort out a
process for that okay thank you Chad I'm
comfortable with that explanation thank
you
Leslie
thanks Mr q and Michael just made my
point that we've got a contractor who's
proposed the event in
so probably so I'm glad Michael's
clarified there's a little bit of work
to do on
a big fact of the Sun that is the first
one I think um what I saw was a
contractor who's also a sincerely
proposed
end up fulfilled the process we've got
in place at the moment
okay look I've got a a few questions and
that's regarding its process as well I
mean we're 10 days out from this event
and I look through Section 3.2 and
schedule 10. it doesn't mention anything
about how long you have to advertise or
notify the public there's no there's no
mention of time now 10 days the reason I
raise this is that if you drive down Don
Street or mainly Don street but in East
Street there's an underground car park
accessible of I think it's under the old
sit building
and then if you've got a Don Street
you've got a car park underneath the
State Insurance I'll stay Insurance
building you've got a lot of car parks
off
uh down within the cargo clubbers of the
courthouse now
how are you going to get to the
occupants of these car parks
um and notify them that come 5 30
they could be completely stranded
landlocked so I can't imagine the event
organizers would allow a car to suddenly
drift down into Don Street
and try and find its merry way out is
that right
so again through chair we we obviously
are aware as Council been minty that
does these things more regularly aware a
lot of those sort of issues and so
Council staff when they receive these
applications start working with the
applicant and saying have you considered
that have you and so we're aware that
correspondence and conversations are
occurring between the applicant in this
case going south and those parts to all
of those those traffic management issues
around the car park Etc have been
managed and the the use of those car
parks are aware of the time limitations
that will occur et cetera Etc right
because it doesn't say that in the
report it just says it just says ICC
website and public notice now I don't
look at the ICC website and I don't read
Public Notices and that's how that's our
statutory obligations but again as part
of this broader piece around working
with the users of our sites we have a
broader piece around making sure that
they
the public are aware of what's going on
they managing those risk courses as I'm
sure you would appreciate ultimately
there's someone disgruntled they'll come
back to us at first instance about why
we close the road rather than the event
organ is so as chair I can rest assure
that those car park owners the people
who pay to be there and and will be
will be notified we have seen I mean we
haven't gone and spoken from a we've
been confirmed that that has occurred
council's been told that's occurred by
the event organizer okay and if they
have to find other alternative parking
because you know they obviously pay for
these parks
do they get reimbursed or how does that
work
short answer is no because obviously
it's Friday night and you have Friday
night we still have Friday night
shopping which we do now with the yeah
building there Michael uh three yourself
chair um it is the responsibility of the
event coordinators that should come up
with their traffic management plan and
that includes notifying the effect
directly affected parties to come up
with a plan on how to use those
facilities
um our team does work with them before
presenting these road closures forward
to make sure that they have done
due diligence in relation to that and
actually work with those parties
um so Russell was here would say he's
had those conversations with the event
coordinator okay and um he's seemed
satisfied to put the sport okay right
okay we'll just see uh there are any any
Fallout that may affect the next event
um Mr Clark yeah just a piece of mind
last time we had the Street closed when
we had the pipe bands and kids
activities there
um the owners of the car park advise
their clients there was going to be a
club and it didn't seem to be any
problems that they were quite Keen to
have the activity into it they just got
a bit of notice to say guy there we
couldn't come back with the force during
the time it was close
right yeah just so there are when you
look at all the separate driveways that
go down the back of various buildings
yeah there are quite a few people and
they aren't those car Parks aren't owned
by like a car park owner like the two
big underground ones they're they're
sort of just private spaces yeah okay
right any further questions
we've got uh three recommendations
there
um clients will take them all at once
have someone move them
uh moved Leslie and seconded rear and
put that motion
pull those in favor hey against
that is Carrie
okay we're gonna adjourn to fix the
noise and the sound system if we just
um five minutes please uh just stops
okay we're back on now thank you uh
for the technicians there sorry for your
life arrival again
right later getting late twice
sorry the Chairman's lost his glasses
foreign
takes us now to the water supply the
search for another source and due to
illness within the infrastructure
Services management team our chief
executive is
going to speak to us today about this uh
thank you chair I'll take the report as
read but um just add a few comments um
fiercely apologies from the
infrastructure team I've got the our
water specialist their infrastructure
manager and our GM of infrastructural
down uh SEC today and most of them can't
actually talk so no not much Point let
me even zooming in
um
so like I say I'll take this report as
read a few things I'd like to highlight
one of the key reasons for requesting
the bring forward of funding is so that
we can do some additional planning
of the consent get another bore down so
we can get ready for a consent for the
environment Southland so we can
progress through with getting our
additional water sourced having said
that I note that the languages change
from emergency water to additional water
once it's connected to the network you
need to keep it running and circulating
that's where that additional water
comment comes in so it's a search for
another water source it's from that
perspective
just to ensure Council
as aware where this currently is it's
this is currently the current testing is
on our own area the the historical
Precinct that we still own so we are
still looking for the Water Source
available there and that's where we'll
be doing some boards should that prove
to be anything different than that then
we will need to come back to Council in
relation to consent Associated to
another site from that perspective but
at the moment that's the site we are
testing
writing it up to questions
is Tom
Cruise here
um
Michael I may be wrong in this because I
wasn't here but my understanding was
that the original proposition
at the proposition at some stage was
that this would be particularly an
emergency supply backup of something
went wrong
um at branscombe
um but we are now talking about the
possibility of it being a routine Supply
now the concern I have about that not
whether that's right or wrong
but provide occasion costs money
and it means a lot more costs in terms
of you know ongoing investigation let's
try let's let's try that let's think
about this
so I think it's important that we come
here Landing in whether it's an
emergency supply or whether it's a
routine Supply early
and I'm not really clear why we've moved
away from the emergency supply option
but I mean my comment really is just to
I guess urge officers to it let's let's
bring a clear decision because when you
get a clear decision to make then avoid
a lot of again I'll call it
prevarication costs they're not going to
run any hundreds of thousands of dollars
throw yourself to your um the the
wording is quite carefully around
additional not um
that's not a routine water supply from
that perspective and and not emergency
and the reason say not emergency is we
have to keep it connected and keep it
flowing we have to keep it circulating
that doesn't mean you have to have the
full lot and full capacity operating at
all times
um so that's what a wedding change
um but yes knowledge acknowledged and
aware in relation to the additional
costs that they could pose if it was a
routine
this is not a routine water supply at
this stage but we still need to do all
the testing quality etc for having it
connected into our Network so because we
don't want it to
um
cause any untoward in relation to
existing Network so that's our our key
aspect and make sure there's no health
concerns in relation to this particular
supplier so
that's the nature of that original the
current investigation
thank you
um thank you Mr chair I went through
um and I've looked at previous Council
information about this particular
exploration for water supply and I had a
couple questions
um
the two balls that we have already
have shown that there's indication of
one accessible water
to it according to the
lws
um
further tests we needed in terms of
whether that water was drinkable
is that correct
yeah through such a yes I'm
understanding in this document here that
we're being asked to consider funding
700 000 poor
typically explored in order to then move
towards a consent
so what would the third bore
give us in terms of complete
satisfaction that we have met the
exploration objectives
through yourself chair that that is one
in relation to the science from
environment Southland I can't answer
from that perspective I will have to
come back to Council in relation to that
I can get my understanding but I can't
give you the exact scientific
uh
the these certain conditions in relation
to the um water grading that we need to
have tested as part of our mental
environment Southlands requirements for
a consent we do not feel as though they
have been met or they do not feel as
though they've been met at this
particular stage and we would
be uncomfortable and feel as though
we'll be putting uh Community
potentially in a drinking water standard
at risk if we do not do further testing
we so that's kind of the direction from
environment Southampton but it's also we
we support that position because we're
not 100 comfortable ourselves yet we've
only done
um let's say two ball testing from that
perspective and we haven't got uh the
reliability of the Water Source or the
known it's a very unknown water source
from that perspective so
from that perspective
that's why this recommendations come
through so we can get that Reliance
relation to the standard award
thank you okay Peter yeah thank you I
just uh
going to make a comment you know water
is top top priority for our city
um over 20 years ago
this same thing was tabled at a council
meeting then Darren's not here today
Council of that though but we were told
back then
20 years ago once the city the Civic
Theater upgrade was completed
water would be top priority why the
delay what progress has been made oh we
had Venture Southland at the time
employed people to do a mapping
sure if I have all the land around
invercargill and Southland we've come up
with nothing just think of the
ramifications if
something happened at Frank's home
we'd probably have
two days Supply in a reservoirs in town
if water was restricted that those
reservoirs say would be
enough there for three to five days then
would have nothing the city would come
to a standstill just think of the
ramifications everything would stop but
we must future proof our infrastructure
and making a alternate or another supply
of water available why has it taken so
long
we've done all the mapping there's a
large river that flows just to the east
of invercargill comes from the Lakes
district and the enabs down at Ty and
that water quality has been tested
nothing's happened
if we don't have water
we're buggered
and you can speak first if you're like
yeah thank you through yourself to your
I'll answer part of the question I can't
answer the history the full history I
not present during that time what I can
highlight to councilors we have tried to
give certainty of supply for by putting
in an alternative pipeline from breaks
home to give us more comfort that we
have
some protective measures in relation to
our bank's home site so that's the the
need for that additional ranks home
pipeline that we're being currently
putting into the ground
the treatment process down at ranksome
does have another a number of fail safes
in relation to that you'd need to lose
the whole site
the cost of doing
going from another Riverway from that
perspective was seen as quite
prohibitive from that perspective and
it's quite expensive to put that sort of
component in so we looked to one that
was within our boundaries that's hence
why they've gone gone down the ball
front
I I tend to agree about the importance
in relation to these pieces of work
hence why it's one of the first reports
that's coming through while I'm in in
the role of CE so you can see that the
importance of water is pretty pretty
important from our gender
to to be accelerated
thank you Mia client just to reinforce
from the last term that um
I think we identified last two minutes
early early this term that we've got
through Urgent needs in the city housing
renewable energy and and the alternative
water supply from my assessment we're
the only city of this size in the
country that doesn't have an alternative
water supply so that's a huge risk as
Peter quite rightly see you just can't
survive on two days and but not only
that large industries that want to come
here are not going to come here if they
need water that can only be guaranteed
for two days
um so if you think about the hydrogen
plant
certainly the aquaculture and Bluff and
data banks will require water now some
of those will take potable water which
means that they can be post-treatment
plants at the other end of the of the
pipeline as it were but certainly I
think if we we start considering the
aquaculture and Bluff we're going to
need more water there's no doubting that
so I'm very much in favor of going down
the track of the what the paper suggests
Korea
um thank you Mr chair just picking up on
what the Mia's just said there was a
discussion that we'd had earlier in our
Council term about those large
Industries and there had been a
um particular industry that was quite
Keen to help with our exploration and
project of uh an alternative water
supply are those talks still in
discussion is there anything happen
since then yeah I can yeah it can help
you with that chair yes um certainly
when I've spoken to Woodside which is
the big partner coming in with Meridian
for their plant they've gone to the line
of saying well hey we don't need fresh
water out the front end we could use
potable water we'll just post the
treatment
so that has two benefits for us
one we don't have to find a place to get
rid of it because uh water the water is
not going to be a medical once we get
our next consent
um but over and above that um it's
freeze more they would put in some
infrastructure to bring it from wherever
the treatment is being done back up to
wherever their site is for their
hydrogen plant so they're prepared to
contribute to the cost they'll run the
filters to take out whatever
based on chemicals they need to take
over that treatment process and then
they they use it so they don't require
fresh water so that means less at the
front end for us less that we have to
treat easier to dispose off at least
cost and they'll help with some um some
infrastructure those are all ongoing
discussions and they seem quite keen on
there
Michael a through self-chair and just in
support of what Lemire has said they're
very active discussions going on
um what I would say is if their
infrastructure they were putting in they
need reliable water source and we do
have drought periods within Southland um
surprisingly so
um and during those periods it's about
potential storage they a lot of the
industries that are thinking about
locating themselves and and invercargill
or Southland uh do do we need reliable
access
um and that is where it goes towards
potable water
their other option of course is to put
out down their own but we're having
active discussions with them about that
because if they're putting down their
own then we've got further issues with
their without the supply ourselves
because it would potentially be going
into the same Supply Source that's
unknown and they'd have the same
consenting issues so we're on the same
Journey with them they're actively
working with us so that one of us is
doing the investigation from that
perspective
another just one final one so I'm
looking
on a document Under The Heading of
financial implications and I'm looking
at the project spend of seven hundred
thousand dollars
that you're requesting be brought
forward is that
actual worked out Crossings or are we
going to be back again asking for more
funding to be allocated to this project
through yourself tier we've got we've
got reasonable cost expectations because
we've already done two board testing so
that gives us a bit more comfort in the
cost
sorry Leslie
that's okay
um
I'm going last I was I
was a year 2000.
there was a there was a great deal of
exploration
um the windley river the dunsdale street
the otapiri stream the purokino the lake
heroko lake monowa we even looked at
Lake
and using uh Fogo straight sea water
some of those which have been
extensively looked at over what are we
now that was two thousand but this is
now 2023. a good number of years but
some of those alternatives
need a very long pipelines a number of
them weren't going to be potable water
they were going to be extremely costly
and several of them needed dams
finally having found the Chatham
formation under the Southland plains as
a viable source that we need to do
exploration for and that we can now
further rather than looking again at any
of those appendix one alternatives
um and I'm sure that um you know the
idea of using like monowai would give us
some problem in the yl river
environmental area
um
I I just think really this is a
no-brainer to proceed with the
exploration of the chaplain formation
it's answering everything we have been
looking for for more than 20 years it's
the best possibility we have ever come
up with in this time
um we've got the expert saying this is
worth the additional exploration and and
we we know because we consulted on it
that if population is very much behind
us finding this alternative water supply
so I'm I'm just very keen that we go
ahead and okay this and and get this
progress to the real estate
right
um yeah look like as far as expiration
goes this to me is Cheer
is the most sensible form of uh Source
if we went for another River you'd be
faced with the same problems of drought
or a stream or whatever or contamination
we're talking we're talking the Chatham
formation goes back to the early myosin
period we're talking 16 million years
ago talking
um and the the water
is is we don't know how old the water is
but it's seriously old and we've got
control at least a wee bit of control
from contamination uh obviously it gets
recharged somehow but at 220 meters
um that we're drawing from
uh this you know if we've looked at all
these other options it's been worth even
though it
going back 20 years you've got to start
sometime we still haven't got a museum
we talked about that 30 years ago so uh
as Leslie said we need to move on with
this and um
Leslie would you like to move the two
recommendations I'll be very happy to do
that just checking that uh seconded
Peter
I'll put that all those in favor all
right against that's Carrie thank you
thank you
it takes us to the name
name is for Inverrary
of our routing manager
Finance
um
so good afternoon councilors this is a
paper that has been a long time coming
we've been working with the developer
for these names for these two roads for
good nine months in relation to get num
names that are compliant with their
policy we have put this forward noting
that we have only received those three
names
and I'll take any questions
right look I'm just going to jump in
here earlier's cheer and say that um we
do have a preferred option from
the developer is requesting this and
that is
um that uh
is written down
that the West
Road be named Johnson close and at the
East Road name be Huntley place now uh
I would like to actually move that we
insert those into recommendation too
yeah
okay does anyone have a problem with
with that I'd like to speak to that
we have an asking for
the post names for these roads
and we still have not
been able to achieve to have something
that's relevant to the city
um
I don't agree
um simply for the reason being is that
the developer has put forward three
names not the three for each street is
to make them compliant but I look at the
family history behind the reason why he
wants to call them Johnson clothes or
Huntley clothes and it's Scottish
history and you know we've got lots of
Scottish history here
um and I whilst you know
I've I do support
um the names that he's given
um I see them as being totally relevant
um what the provided was issue a really
good background as to why those names
have been put forward to us I don't
think we should flip them out too
quickly if there's nothing else that's
been proposed
here's the spelling
um I hear what you're saying and I think
I they provided a lovely capture of the
rationale behind the names but we still
continue
having other names
that are not really relevant to here
um
executive to speak to this uh three
years through yourself cheer
um this goes back to the last um Council
in relation to a new policy that we see
it in relation to Road naming
um this subdivision given the time frame
that Patricia has put forward to you
um actually fell before we actually
signed off that particular policy From
perspective of having two Rail options
as well as three Road names for each
Road
and these the names that have been
provided are in consistent nature to the
subdivision names that are there
that is the theme that's been throughout
that whole Hub subdivision but from our
perspective it it would not be compliant
with the current policy as it is worded
but having said that this was before
subdivision was before the policy was
put into place just wanted to clarify
that item
Tom
um oh look the only thing I was going to
add is the the third option was gatley
and it says but there's no information
in gatley gatley and Huntley are like
invercargill and Winston they're you
know side by side Villages as it were I
mean they're not as big as invercargill
and went in but that's the context of it
um I mean my own viewers I don't
particularly like proper names being
used you know people's names
so the three are probably quite like
Gatling and Huntley but I I because
Johnson's an individual's name
but I mean I don't have any problem if
people want to goby Johnson and hardly
but I just wanted to see that's what
that's what happened that's where gatley
comes from
Leslie
counselor Kimball has just made it's a
Pity that considering what the old
policy was in the request for the three
names it's just a real developer wasn't
serious enough to give us the
information on the third option it would
have been helpful
um you know to to get the paper here and
just have the blank no background to the
third option
um shows a a wee bit of a keyless
attitude I'm not going to be a full vote
against the two preferred options I just
think I think the message does need to
go to developers that we are serious
about the policies we have in place and
if they couldn't
um
is easily as councilor Campbell has been
able to come up with the background for
the name gartly
um
if the developer can't just give those
few sentences
um it does somewhat make a mockery of
the policy which did ask for the
provision of three names at the time I
agree it was before we had altered the
policy to say we would like to see to
Rio names here but I just think it's
we can expect developers to be a little
bit better than to just broadly put in
for the third option no background to
the name
okay look I I personally think the
developers met the requirements and that
history of the two names I think is
um the third one
um
I don't know what the reason why I
didn't do it but we just need to clarify
that Huntley is actually for the
Huntley close it is
um and that is the East right we can't
actually
um
we it's determined by the nature the
size of the street whether it's close or
road or way right um so it is just has
um suggestion is that they're called
close but I'm not sure that's what they
will they could be they could end up as
that but that's why we've just we always
only just approved the first time and
it's per legislation and regulation what
the following but whether it's away a
street a drive
in that case we have got them around the
wrong way because Huntley is for the
east as far as I read in his request
if you go to page
and the West is Johnson yeah
so close doesn't mean road closure no no
no different thing
it's very close neighborly
way
right wasn't
it
very cool okay thanks any any further
discussion regarding the three
recommendations we have there Mr Mayor
just a reflection I guess through each
year um this will be an ongoing issue
for us
where we have policy that requires or
suggests that we promote more Terrier
names
but I'm against that we also have the
ability of developers to put forward
what they think so we're going to have
an ongoing tension here so for items
sake of a developer was to come into
town and that say they were Chinese
based and they wanted to put some
Chinese names and would we agree to that
um so this will be an ongoing
issue that we'll have to address
obviously not this one because it
predates the policy change that's
ongoing it will be I guess an area of
tension that we'll have to address
right okay so can I have someone please
move the three ring magnesiums
put that motion all those in favor
against
and uh no
um pioneers
running against
right activities report
Michael
thank you through yourself to you I'm
going to take this report as read um
noting it's going to be fairly difficult
for Council staff to answer a lot of the
questions in this activity report I'm
not saying don't ask them saying we'll
answer what we can and we will defer or
seek guidance in relation to follow up
on any other questions that come out of
that so we will attempt our best could
we if I mean some of the items uh you
know you've got the
there's a few there could we ask
questions at the council meeting at the
end of the well perhaps
we'll wait I'll just wait oh I would
suggest um chair we do the questions now
and if we have to we'll bring the
answers
Council Stuart yeah on the CCTV thing
that's a real major worry to me like a
lot of people don't feel safe and
invercargill at the present moment
there's a lot of crime going on
um what sort of timeline we got for this
okay look I can't wait forever I can
talk to that Russell was going to talk
to that but I had a word for them a
couple of weeks ago so what that the
current thing is that is happening is
the design of the network that the
cameras set on and that's probably the
most critical thing so all these cameras
plug in and they will come back on their
own network to the to the recorder
um that has to be done that is a
separate contract that will be a
separate contract to the supplier with
the cameras and once that done it makes
it really easy to go out to the
marketplace and to a camera people and
they they don't have to worry about that
they they know it's all provided the
power everything so that from my
understanding will be going out to
Tinder shortly
and once that is then done and sorted
then we can then move well we'll
obviously have the cost back from that
and that'll give us then a more defined
Budget on what we can do it won't stop
us on the cameras it'll just allow I
guess how much we can spend in the first
in the first lot to start with so it is
definitely happening and I've been I've
been following it up okay yeah
uh any other questions regarding the
activities report
I had a few around oh sorry Mr Man yeah
just two things it would be probably
helpful from a comms perspective if we
got the message about the CCTV out so
people have some idea I mean it's very
quite recent every second quarter I get
is around youth crime and idiot Behavior
which is even a lower tariff issues so
I've got a meeting later this week with
a police Commander to see how we can
deal with some of this just disruptive
behavior but certainly having the
cameras in place would help certainly
help with that so the process is
happening and it has to happen that in
that order yeah I understand that but if
we could give some rough guidelines we
you know I'm not asking if you do that
now but if we could say look you know
buy buy this coming summer I mean we'll
have cameras in the key CBD areas and
then we'll Outreach to other areas
that'll be fine
um you know be helpful
any other questions rare um
question of basically under the waistney
waste Advisory Group it's asking here
that we approve a budget with their
business plan and education and
communication strategy
um are we touching on this in public
excluded and I can leave that
questioning to them
thank you
secondary application all right
okay
any other
you know the
questions I hit I did have a few around
that stormwater upgrade at D Street and
the traffic management plan and the
um what was happening there but that's
not here to ask the chief executive
so
through self-tier if you can get those
um the D Street ones noted they will be
specific to the people that aren't here
sorry and and we're specifically around
the Heritage component of that too
okay so if yes Alan uh just one quick
question Mr chair um just looking at the
um
street light thing here 74 street light
faults um
I'm just wondering if anybody's ever
sort of noted anything to do with the
darkness of the street lights now
compared to what they were perhaps in
the past it seems because when you're
driving around which I do a lot
um seems awfully dark and you know I
noticed a lot of cows including myself
you have to have your lights on full
beam when you're driving around town
in certain areas has that ever been
sort about talked about or what's
changed I remember they changed the
light bulbs here a few years ago I'm
just wondering if you could maybe up the
wattage or weaver or something that's
possible no I think that's a fair
question uh do you have an answer Miss
yeah I can help some
um over the last term we went through a
progress of updating the old light bulbs
to LED it's quite an extensive period of
doing that one of the one of the
downsides of LED is it's quite Direct
so it's sort of it Narrows in and you
get the light it doesn't spray the light
out so much
and the downside of that it does create
patches where sometimes you think it's
sort of like semi-da when you're looking
at you can see the street that the
surrounding area is quite dark but the
old
the old light bulbs sprayed the light
out of course the problem with that was
they they blew too often and we had
ongoing costs and they were more costly
to run Alan
um I'm pretty sure what that means what
the me is saying with it doesn't resolve
the issue that I'm actually talking
about the streets are the roads are very
very dark look you made a valid point I
think we should get an answer from
Russell when he comes back
um what can be done I don't think it's
on a mood setting you know for for the
evening
um so
I know exactly what you mean I I some
areas and there are definite gaps the
danger of full beam of course in Town
Cars you know people not dipping dipping
you know I mean that's that has its own
its own issues through yourself to your
looks a back in reaction to that no
that's good thank you for that you will
be driving slow though won't you
any further questions or around the
activities report if not uh there are
three recommendations there
have someone move that thanks Barry
seconded Peter put that
I can't be buried sorry Barry uh you're
not officially on this no no so it's
moved uh Ria seconded Peter
uh put that all those in favor
against
they uh Carey that takes us
to the minutes of the waste net
public session
um any
questions regarding that we just are we
receiving these or these for information
only
yeah
okay
so these are for information only so any
questions regarding
the public minutes
uh yes Mr Mayor so we're now we're now
talking about the two reports which is
the
paper that I put to the wastenet group
uh meeting was in Gore on the 15th of
May I sent on the 11th of May and the
subsequent Waste Management Group
minutes which are on the 18th of May so
those for those listening in the
um
the wag group or the waste voluntary
group is the governance group I guess of
wastenet and the waste management group
is the uh the staff one that sits below
so just a couple things I want to raise
I mean obviously uh Aaron's not here so
I can't take all the questions to you
but um some things out of that
out of the out of both groups certainly
out of the way Group which is the senior
one
um I tabled a paper to wag
and Gore and I accepted gauze and a bit
of flux at the moment so I understand it
might be under a bit of pressure but it
was disappointing that that paper wasn't
tabled at their meeting even if they
didn't deal with it it just wasn't
tabled I haven't been able to get hold
of the minutes of that meeting and it
seems as though staff have got it but I
I've set a time well I just can't seem
to get the minutes of that of that Gore
meeting and there are some serious
issues in there that we've left behind
for way too long and certainly will be
aware of the glass separation issue
which just can't can't be left for
another 18 months to do so we've got to
be reactive in that air not not sitting
back but the other area is that there
was two requests for funding
for the plastic pelletizing plant the
other Macario which needs to be resolved
fairly quickly so I guess that's one
issue
um and and I'm not sure where we go as a
council if we can't get it past our
colleagues at the at the waste Advisory
Group level whether we go It Alone
um my understanding is that our share of
the um
twice net revenue is 730
000 and we've recently had some
unbudgeted profit come back from uh
recycle sales at 136 000 so we've got
roughly 860 000 potentially sitting in
the bank as it were
um that should be targeted towards uh
doing some additional work or some
unplanned work in the space of glass and
potentially with the plastic plant as
well
um the plastic plant is um country
leading I can tell you that
Eugenie Sage recently made a
presentation to the local government
conference in Wellington and she gave
them a lot of praise for what they're
doing but there's a couple things that
still need to be done with the plan to
make sure it can work at full operation
and doesn't put any
microplastics into the water supply as
the outcome of the end so we've got an
opportunity to uh to lead the country as
it were on it and I think if if and when
it's up and running fully
um I think
the ministry for the environment will
promote it as a something it needs to be
right across the country so in Auckland
they might have seven right of these
plants because of the size of what
they're dealing with but it basically
gives us ability to recycle just about
every single type of plastic you can but
but you might do including bail rep and
building reps so we can't afford that to
sit around for too long so I'm a bit
worried the next
the next wave meeting might not be for
another month or so so there needs to be
some surgery there so I'll try and do
what I can do with that and and the
other areas in the Waste Management
Group which was the staff group
um
I need I need to put forward to Aaron
when she's back but just a signal that
one of the issues in there is the items
of a term for reference for a waste net
review and um
as far as on where they didn't go to uh
the wear group at the 15th of May and
I'd like to know someone online what
sort of review they're doing ways near
be helpful to know it's no secret it's
been a disaster for it's part of a
couple of years now but when if we're
gonna work collectively with the other
councils we've got to get the Buy
otherwise we just need to do our own
thing okay Barry
yeah as far as uh for glass collection
goes if we got any estimates on what the
price of us getting bins
yeah so the process for that is going to
go through the ltp because it's an
improved it's a change of service level
and that's what I understand Michael so
costings and Alternatives that are
available
to to a separate glass collection like
bottle Banks
or the key thing is to get it out of the
recycling
stream yeah so uh that will go through
the ltp but there has been movement
um in the storage of the class and where
it's done
um people who are interested in using
the glass have found
um local a local site to be able to put
that so that's working out well so
everything is slowly progressing that
collection though must go through the
ltp
um
right just me just just to answer the
comments you made it's not just a matter
of the cost of the bins it's a cost of
the product not being taken out of the
system so it tends to go one of two ways
if you leave it in the uh
coming out of Taurus I'm not quite sure
what the color of bins are but if you
leave it like General waste it goes
through the landfill and because it's
heavy it really bumps the cost up from
the landfill if you leave it in the
recycling bin which some people do it
breaks up and Transit and then damages
all the other goods and makes it hard
for us to recycle paper and cardboard in
particular
and and even Plastics when you put them
through the plastic plants having too
high level of glass shards and they
damages the plant as well so
look we're only one of I think three
councils in the country two other
councils don't have glass all the others
do so or whatever they are 50 something
of them Christchurch has some suburbs
that don't do it and Auckland has some
some as well but every other Council
takes it out we just way behind the able
the quicker we do this the better and I
can remember the chair talking about
this 10 years ago or nearly 10 years now
Tom
um
not being your letter
um you identify the classic pelletizer
as a more urgent issue could you just
say a little bit more about that why why
is that and what I don't want sure well
I think the glass will take some time
uh it's very in and the chair have said
that um we need to Source the bins the
giving them out by Bond contractors
about takes about two weeks so that's
not the issue
um but while the other two a bit more
urgent is that um
Governor said that they'll fund 50 of
that funding base so that's that's about
160 between the two two issues
councils need to fund the others the
governor said they're not going to
wholly go into it because the the upside
of it is not just an economic
development and not just a development
from a environmental thing there is an
economic spin to this as well so the
rough figures are that if you you know
can I just um interrupt there can we
look it'd be great to talk about the
figures but I don't want to talk about
them because they are at the moment they
are
um
not public the actual figures require I
like to carry this conversation on when
we can with the other minutes of the
wastek meeting if that suits you Mr
Mayor yeah I wasn't wasn't going to go
into the thing all I was going to say is
that they're because there is an
economic development of washing and
palletizing plastic before it goes away
you get some financial gain from there
so the government's just a little bit
uneasy about just putting the whole
amount of money in themselves so they've
asked the council to do that I think
I'll be here hopefully by the time the
other two councils agree to this so I
guess what I'm flagging is that we might
have to run it alone out of the services
we've got
as soon as Aaron's back I'll try and
progress it okay
okay right okay
um we have a simple recommendation that
we receive these minutes can I have
someone move that
thank you Tom seconded thank you panya
I'll put that
all those in favor
aye against that is Carrie thank you
that's that brings to conclusion the
public section of the meeting can I have
someone please move that we go into
public excluded move Tom secondton Alan
put that all those in favor
aye against that is carried we are now